this is so unlike you brother so  clandestine are you sure you wouldn't  rather just punch your way out if you  keep speaking I just might fine as you  wish  I'm not even here is this better it's  better company at least still we could  be less conspicuous brother you look  ravishing it will hurt no less when I  kill you in this form very well perhaps  you prefer one of your new companion  it's given that you seem to like them so  much this is much better  whoa costumes a bit much so tight but  the confidence I can feel the  righteousness surging hey want to have a  rousing discussion about truth honor  patriotism  what  you could at least furnish me with a  weapon my daggers something at last of a  common sense I thought you liked to race  you